welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Varna Mastro so Joker has been blowing
people's minds since its release and
we're about to dive even deeper into
Arthur flex sinister mind with a deleted
scene oh thank god there is not enough
in this movie currently to tell us what
the hell is actually real and what isn't
we need the deleted goodies we need it
that's right we break down what you
missed and how this seemed that wasn't
included in the movie could actually
help us understand this joaquin phoenix
version of the joker even more than when
you saw it in theaters and of course
this spoiler warning in case you have
not seen the film or our breakdown of
this deleted scene ends up being so
profound that it reveals truths about
yourself that you didn't even know we're
there so how does this deleted scene
help us better understand Joker's
character we break it down for you on
explain just okay in an interview
Joaquin Phoenix revealed that their
words just deleted scenes but deleted
acts implying that there was a lot that
kind of left on the cutting-room floor
or this could also mean that even if the
scenes didn't add up to a lot of total
screen time their content was equivalent
to cutting the entire act to the story
now some of those deleted acts including
a dozen alternate tapes of Arthur
dancing out from the curtains on Murray
Franklin show can't wait to see those
but among those deleted acts was one
with major implications on Arthur's
descent into madness
according to Phoenix there is a scene
that during the shoot we thought was one
of the best scenes and we loved his
behavior in the scene and I'd always
really liked the scene and Todd told me
and said we're cutting that scene out
and at first I thought like wait a
minute
what do you mean we're cutting that
scene out and then of course I saw it
and it was very obvious it has to go now
the scene that Phoenix is referring to
takes place between Arthur and Randall
right after Arthur has been fired from
his clown job or bringing Randall's gun
to a Children's Hospital and then
murdered three bros on the train with
that gun and then dated his imaginary
girlfriend and now he is clearing out
his work Locker Arthur's co-workers
question him wanting to know why he
would bring a gun to a gig Arthur then
throws the question back in randall
saying why don't you ask randall about
it it was his gun I still owe you for
that don't I Arthur then punches out and
exits down the stairwell he vandalized
as a sign changing it from don't forget
to smile too don't smile and this is
where we get our deleted scene right and
it turns out we actually saw part of
this too
via leaked video long before any
trailers came out throughout the past
year now there's no audio for this scene
but marina spend most of her day
squinting at a screen trying to brush up
on her lip reading skills
full disclosure marina cannot relive no
I can't but I can certainly try first we
see Phoenix exiting the stairwell from
his work onto the street he turns around
and spits toward the door along with
punching the time clock in defacing the
sign he clearly has stopped giving an F
or notice that behind them is a massive
mural for amusement mile which would
have been one of the few Easter eggs to
DC Comics and Joker amusement mile is
the location in Gotham City where the
festival grounds are located and has
shown up as a setting for a number of
Batman's battles with Joker anyway
Randall follows Arthur outside yelling
art art holed up
Arthur Waits and Randall approaches
frustrated now it looks like Randall
says what the f he cuts himself off
lowering its voice clearly indicating
these angry Arthur told everyone now
keep in mind at this point in the film
Arthur has used Randall's gun to kill
three rich white dudes on the subway and
it's just making news yeah and now
Randall is confronting Arthur about
whether or not he usually gonna gave him
to commit murder
Arthur puts his arms out and seems to
say I don't know what you're talking
about
Randall comes closer points to him and
grabs Arthur's lapel either trying to
intimidate him or maybe genuinely trying
to connect with him to get him to
confess and Arthur responds Randall I
didn't do anything and I genuinely lip
read that and I got it right
nice Arthur then walks off unbothered
Randall tries to appeal again but Arthur
just wow he says you're crazy and
snatches the clown nose off Randall's
face and throws it down the street
Randall goes chasing after it now it's
interesting that this exchange was
removed because it foreshadows Arthur's
later murder of Randall like he sends
Randall out into a dangerous busy street
chasing his nose showing that isn't care
if Randall gets hurt and he goes for the
head just like he will violently strike
Randall's head later this exchange also
shows us the transition from Arthur to
Joker
after the murder on the subway Arthur's
demeanor has changed entirely from the
way he interacted with Randall earlier
in the film Arthur goes from submissive
and weak too confrontational and
aggressive perhaps this scene was
deleted because it revealed too early
Arthur's will
to be confrontational not only with
strangers but also with people he knows
really well Arthur should be more sad
about losing his income but instead the
scene shows that the murders in the
subway actually triggered the opposite
reaction he feels powerful instead and
he's still more of a mystery wildcard
this way like later when he confronts
strangers like Bruce Wayne Alfred Thomas
Wayne and when he kills his mother those
hid as bigger shocks now that we're left
a bit more guessing what Arthur's
capable of and it shifts the power
dynamic between Arthur and Randall
Randall is played by Glenn Fletcher an
amazing character actor who played the
villain the yellow king in true
detective so good so scary this dude is
a force of nature
clearly he was cast to pose a major
threat to Arthur but now Randall's more
out of sight out of mind for better or
worse since I think we could always use
a bit more flesh Larry if it makes
Arthur's sudden outburst on him in their
apartment less justified and more
terrifyingly sudden more of the actions
of a true madman and by removing the
movements of Arthur's journey that would
have made that snap a bit more
understandable we see how Joker's
departure from sanity becomes a little
more yes do you think this scene should
have stayed in the film comment down
below also if you're trained in
lip-reading let me know because I have a
sidekick for you subscribe to new rock
stars and thank you to our patron Messi
Legaspi for being soo awesome I'm Erik
Bosse to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at a ball I'm marina masters
follow me on Twitter at Marina master
hey do you think they offer lip-reading
is like a course at junior colleges yeah
but I think you have to pass like basic
math at first
[Music]